[موسيقى]
الخيزران مادة أصبحت
تحظى بتقدير وإعجاب شديد
لأنني عندما أقود دراجة تكون فريدة من نوعها ،
لا أحد يمتلكها ، فهي فريدة من نوعها بالنسبة لي ، لذلك
تحصل على قدر كبير من الاهتمام وأنت في
دراجة الفقاعات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسمي Cobra dancer ، أنا المؤسس
التنفيذي لشركة boomers international ، وهي
شركة تصنع دراجات
وإكسسوارات من الخيزران في غانا الخام ، لذا فإن بومرز هي
مؤسسة اجتماعية تقوم في الواقع بتدريب
الشباب في المجتمعات الريفية
وتوظيفهم.  نصنع
دراجات وإكسسوارات من الخيزران ، لذلك نصنع
منتجات مختلفة من الخيزران باستخدام
المتسربين من المدرسة في الغالب والذين لم تكن
لديهم الفرصة للعودة إلى المدرسة
ولم تكن لديهم الفرصة
للذهاب للحصول على وظيفتي ، لدينا
أنواع مختلفة من الدراجات  تشتري المدينة
أجسامًا جبلية تشتري الطرق والطرق
للقيام بهذه الدراجات ذات العجلات الثلاثية للأطفال مقابل
كل ما يمكن أن يفعله البامبو بشكل طبيعي من شأنه أن
يفعل كل شيء تقريبًا
مثل الفولاذ الذي يمكن أن يفعله
الخيزران  ر لأن الخيزران هو في الواقع
أقوى نبات تجده نوعًا ما
بسبب الطريقة التي تم بها تكوين الألياف ،
هذا ما قاله السيد.
دراجة Bumble فريدة من نوعها ويقدر الفقراء
كثيرًا في الوقت الحالي لدينا حوالي 40
موظفًا بشكل مباشر ونقوم أيضًا بتوظيف
حوالي 20 شخصًا بشكل غير مباشر يقومون
بحصاد الألياف التي
نستخدمها للتغليف ، حيث نشارك في حوالي 200 مزارع
للذهاب إلى زراعة خشب البامبو التي
يستقبلها كل عامل  أجرًا جيدًا جدًا
ثم ندفع أيضًا مقابل
تأمين الشركاء وهذا
من شأنه أن يمكّنهم وستكون قادرة على
إسعادهم ولهذا السبب أتيت إلى المصنع
وكل الرجال سعداء دائمًا بفعل
ما يفعلونه لأننا
عش كعائلة
بين عام 2014 عندما بدأنا العمل
التجاري وعام 2018 قمنا ببيع ما يقرب من
4000 دراجة على مستوى العالم ،
والهدف هو إنتاج ما بين 5000 6000
دراجة في السنة وهو ما يترجم إلى
حوالي 500 دراجة في الشهر ، الجزء المفضل لدي
من عملي هو الاستيقاظ  كل
صباح وأدركت أنك
لا تفكر في نفسك فقط ولكنك
تفكر في المجتمع بأكمله
كيف تجعل المجتمع أفضل كيفية
تمكينك  الناس لتقوية
أنفسهم
[موسيقى]